So what types of shared
memory hardware do we have?
We can have multiple single cores that
share the same physical address space,
so all of them can each
address to any memory address.
And the examples we have seen
of these are the UMA and NUMA.
Both of them actually
are individual cores,
each of them being able to
access the entire address space.
The other extreme is to only have one
core and then do multi-threading,
basically, run two threads by
just time-sharing the same core.
So, because they're now running
really on the same core,
they're naturally accessing
the same physical memory.
So, we get the shared memory
behavior simply by virtue of
actually not having more than one core.
And now the question is,
is there something in-between them?
Because this is not really capable of
benefiting from having multi-threading.
We can have hardware multi-threading
support in one core that
actually tries to benefit from
there being multiple threads.
This hardware multi-threading
can be at the coarse-grain
where we change the thread we
are working on every few cycles.
And we now need to have hardware
support that switches between threads
this often, because without hardware
support, we would be spending
all of the time just saving and
restoring registers of these threads.
So we actually need to now have every
thread has its own set of hardware
registers and so on.
So there is hardware support needed for
this.
We can have fine-grain
hardware multi-threading where
every cycle we are working
on another thread.
This, of course, needs even more
hardware support because now we need to
be able to very quickly
change between these threads.
And, we can also have
simultaneous multi-threading or
SMT, where in any given cycles,
we could be doing instructions that
belong to these different threads.
This is called
Simultaneous Multi-Threading or SMT.
And it's also called Hyper Threading
by some manufacturers of processors.
So now, we need hardware support for
any one of these three.
And, of course, the hardware support
becomes more extensive as we move from
coarse-grain, to fine-grain,
to simultaneous.
So the question is, but
what do we benefit by kind of sharing
the same core by multiple threads.
Don't we get the same thing as here?